all right here's the first story we have
from The Daily Mail uh I don't know Phil
do you want to just read the headline
because no we think you don't have any
idea
old man uh you think I don't know how
[ __ ] old I am Joe Biden 80 says
vents to allies about how he's fed up
with fixation on his age as Democrats
speculate if he will run for president
in 2024. this one actually is really
funny uh Biden turned 80 in November
he'd be 82 82 years old if he wins and
takes office in 2025 he is already the
oldest man ever elected president I'm
pretty sure if Trump wins he would also
be the oldest president ever elected yep
so I guess this is just where we're at
what is this look I guess maybe we just
want to rag on Joe Biden a little bit
but yes
but the question I have is why is it
that old people are clinging to power
like this and where are the younger
people to to cling it back and actually
start leading I I guess you're running
Riley you're younger yeah look I'm
younger than Biden but you know yeah
most people alive are yeah
[Laughter]
um Truth uh you know for me look I won
this office as state treasurer from an
older guy he had been in office for 24
years was elected in 1996 uh and uh look
we that's what we ran on I ran on
modernizing the office changing the
office bringing it into uh this Century
um which he was like I did modernize the
office in 1996 we got the internet uh
can you really say that yes uh so bless
his heart yes that's all you can say is
that poor man but you know to your point
them clinging to power I'm the first
Republican elected in West Virginia as
State Treasurer in 92 years
and this is West Virginia and it's you
know people just Clinging On to first
elected uh first Republican elected in
92 Years first Republican elected 92
years wow and you know I mean it does
take this generation stepping up and
taking some risks that was a risk for me
I'm taking the risk here to run for
Congress in 24. and uh yeah I mean it
just takes this generation to just step
up and do something about it because if
you don't I mean if you don't keep
taking shots at kind of the uh
establishment class yeah they will
continue to persist we do have uh Ocasio
Cortez you know yeah yes he's Millennial
yes do you count as a millennial or are
you a Gen X because I'm Gen X I think
I'm right on the border yeah because 42
you said yeah so 1980 and depending what
the internet says sometimes I'm Gen X
sometimes I'm um I think I call it
zenial yeah yeah Ian's the same age I
just wonder if
people that are Gen X
generally we've kind of been fairly the
aloof and detached generation like
people didn't hear a whole lot about Gen
X like
Millennials kind of stormed onto the
scene before people started paying
attention to Gen X it was like everyone
was complaining about the Boomers we
were kind of just quietly you know
existing and then the Millennials came
and were just like pay attention to me
and uh the you know Gen X is kind of
like you know and I wonder if that's if
that kind of attitude of being aloof is
kept Gen X
away from trying to be in in government
I'm I'm this is kind of I guess
spitballing here I think jet X is like
the Forgotten generation kind of because
everyone everyone's mad at Boomers and
disgusted by Millennials and Gen X is
just like right we're here too guys
correctly exists I I just go to work
every day you know that's the thing like
whenever I bring up Boomer stuff I'll
say like you know the Boomers did this
good this bad and the Millennials are
doing this I get a bunch of comments
where they're like Tim I'm Gen X We
Exist I'm like I know I know it's just
there's not really much to say because
you're doing all right yeah right that's
right you got some good music uh you're
you're running some companies you're not
doing horrible things boomers are doing
you didn't make Star Trek the Next
Generation but you maybe worked on it
with the Boomers but you're also not a
bunch of psychopaths for the most part
so I'm chill with Gen X I think they're
cool people for the most part Gen X has
been has been uh fairly benign and right
and inoffensive aside from the fact that
stop generalizing and collectivizing I I
just wanna I just want to bring it back
to this uh This original story here
because uh Biden still thinks he's in
charge here uh obviously clearly there's
bigger powers above him that do call the
shots here but we have to consider that
with the way that the Democratic party
is shaping up and even sources coming
out through the corporate media saying
that he's going to announce his bid for
the presidency after uh this holiday
season there's a big chance that he
actually might run and he might win
especially with the way that the
Democrats have been fortifying elections
I think it's it's very clear more than
ever that we could have a second Biden
Administration especially with the
advancements of Technology especially
with how useful he has been to the
current ruling class that has been using
him in order to push on the most
unpopular policies ever on Humanity
especially with the way that they have
played out destroying domestic energy
and I could go on and on and on but it's
a deliberate action I think he's there
for a reason and I think he might be
there for the next six years Luke you're
exciting the doomers hey hey I'm being
real here hold on you know I just gotta
we remember the photo where Biden had
the the IV track marks or whatever yes
they're they're they're they're cranking
him full of whatever he's on stem cells
young people baby blood probably they do
it in Mexico don't joke here this is not
crazy stuff they literally do this stuff
uh in some places around the world uh
some people might say adrenicarm some
people might say this hey okay that's
another thing but but the Redstone but
the stem cells and the young people
blood is not out of uh the realm of
possibility here we've got to slow down
a little bit you said baby blood and
adrenochrome hold on
some people might say adrenochrome I
said baby blood it's okay but it's
probably what we have heard is these
stories where powerful Elites hire like
19 year old bodybuilders to do blood
transfusions every other week black boys
Silicon Valley but yeah right right you
know so I don't know what they're
cranking Biden full of but we saw the IV
marks he's an old guy at the very least
he's getting like a vitamin drip they
probably come in vitamin drip yeah once
a week they hook up the IV and they give
him you know vitamin C vitamin B all
that stuff listen look they bring in a
Brina Mitch right they close in the room
they start getting all the liquids from
all the human body bodily orifices and
then they start summoning the the
entities and then they this probably
literally happens and they probably are
like keep him in power he's too good for
us and the demons are like okay yes
we'll do this translated that's probably
what's happening translate into English
what really happens he flies back to
Delaware a lot he probably is going in
there so they can bring in doctors that
they don't track the doctor then brings
a vitamin drip IV bag maybe NAD you know
if you watch Joe Rogan you know exactly
what's going on and they're probably
stem cells definitely stem cells is
actually like like I don't want to say
common I want to I want to submit one
quick idea before before I let you on
I I don't think you're right because I
believe all that stuff that you're
talking about works and Joe Biden
doesn't Fair Point fair point but it's a
certain age at a certain age though I
mean there's only so much you could do
to fix the system right you could keep
him up and running but but you know with
the way that things are going and the
way that truly things are run in our
political system why wouldn't he have a
body double why wouldn't the body double
be in there when he's so convenient for
the ruling class I mean I think that's
worth speculating on I don't have any
proof I don't have any evidence of this
but if the president of Venezuela has a
body double why wouldn't the U.S
president have a body double no I I
definitely agree with that they they
there was like that Viral photo that of
Hillary Clinton that everyone said
wasn't really Hillary Clinton and I'm
like I don't know I'm not gonna get in
it but she did not look like Hillary
Clinton if you're a powerful military
military involved or state official yeah
I really doubt the U.S would not give
you a body double yeah Kim Jong-un has a
couple of them right and the United
States doesn't have of them come on I
want all that to be true I don't know
that I believe it but it's a much cooler
story than like not having body doubles
I don't I don't I don't know that I see
I have seen any kind of evidence that
would lead me to believe that but I mean
well I also you know I there's a lot of
things that I that the government has
done that I would not have right Riley's
got like two or three body doubles yeah
that's right yeah West Virginia state
treasurer I I need one to come in do 360
Flip for me that's right but uh the the
thing is though for the left he is the
best candidate he's the greatest
candidate they can have because he
believes in essentially whatever they
tell him to believe in yeah and all he's
ever wanted his life in his entire life
was to be president he's ran several
times he's there this is the retirement
gig and talking about Millennials well
the White House is chocked full of them
and they are running the show every
left-wing thing that you can think of
has been pushed forward by this
Administration I mean it makes almost
like the Obama Administration look like
a mod moderate Administration compared
to what's happening right now in the
Bible we had that viral video of the
biggest Caravan ever to cross the
southern border and it's just it's kind
of crazy to me that you can be politely
and calmly saying something like hey
it's really bad that there's a bunch of
kids living under a bridge and dying in
the desert and being trafficked and
young girls being raped and coyotes in
Black Market
and just nothing happens
so why what are important things going
on he literally said that are you going
to go to the Border no because there's
more important things going on I just
want to finish my so why wouldn't they
keep this kind of show running when it's
so beneficial to them and second I met
someone that looks exactly like me and I
was like I need your number hold on I
might need you in the future and if I'm
thinking this way what is the U.S
federal government thinking about I mean
it's you look at Face Off you look at
the advancements in plastic surgery
artificial intelligence anything yes you
look at it you look at age
I'm saying do anything is possible here
I mean if you're bringing Obama you do
an operation I mean I mean I want to say
that I want to say that it's silly but
if you go and you read history about
things that the CIA has actually tried
and attempted they'll try anything
incapacitated yeah wkr was not able to
rule but his wife was ruling with the
special interest with the people behind
him they were making all the decisions
Reagan's brain was gone exactly so this
happened before why wouldn't it happen
now why wouldn't it happen during the
second Administration it's like uh you
know that that vacation movie with
Bernie what's his name weekend at Bernie
yeah it's like we get him Bernie's two
they made they made it to the second
version so there's the likelihood that
there's going to be another version of
this I mean do you think there's any
point where he's brought some issue or
policy and he says no
I I mean by his yes yes but they
probably he probably tries to say no and
goes and then they're just like it's
good like they take his hand with a
rubber stamp and he's like whoa and then
they stamp yes
I can't do anything about it I don't
think that I don't think he has any care
about any of the policies that are being
presented at all yo they put him they
put him in a fake office remember when
he was young he was at a sound stage and
it screens behind him and they're like
that's right you're the president and
he's like
yeah I don't think he does I think that
I think that you know there's not a
whole lot of argument that you know
decisions are being made without Biden's
input there's you know most people think
that the they're the chief of staff and
and other people in the administration
are actually making the day-to-day calls
and then the overall broad policy
decisions are not being made by by Joe
Biden because the overall broad policy
decisions are kind of kind of baked into
the philosophy that the left has now you
know it's like you kind of can predict
what the policy positions they're going
to be looking for the the the things
that the activists are acting for are
asking for the uh the you know the
people in in positions of Power are
doing their best to deliver to the
activists I just got to make sure people
know like whenever I say something crazy
I gotta pull up a source because I
remember we had one time that uh uh Luke
mentioned Bill Gates was creating uh
computer chips to implanting people to
stop him from getting pregnant and I was
like oh come on Luke that's and then we
Googled it and it was true so we have
this from the New York Post Biden mocked
for Truman's show presidency over fake
White House set that's right they put
Biden in a in a set with TV screens as
fake windows and they put different
things on the back that's what they're
doing to this man I just want to make
sure everybody knows that actually
happened that we know of they do just
you know they're gonna keep rolling them
out and if you go flash back to Biden 20
years ago Biden 30 years ago whatever it
is different guys different guy policies
were very very different now he's
abortion with no limits whatsoever uh
but in a not too distant past that's not
where he was they have a fake White
House set why wouldn't they have a fake
White House President right I'm serious
I'm surprised they didn't work with
Disney and and started uh one of the
rides but the thing where it's like you
know one of the rides in Disney where
you just kind of sit there and then the
theater kind of moves like here's now
the president of the United States and
you get the AI generated hologram puppet
coming out there that's literally
something that could be conceivable and
could be happening right now especially
because when you look at military Terry
technology it is usually 30 years ahead
of what's on the general public usually
knows about but the point that we've
been like the the thing that we're kind
of saying is it doesn't matter if it's
Joe but like if Joe Biden has a body
double or not because Joe Biden isn't
making the calls anyways yeah so if it's
the in if it's Joe Biden or a body
double of Joe Biden it doesn't matter
because we've already kind of agreed
that the chief of staff at the White
House is making the calls and the actual
Direction the left is going is going
that way without Joe Biden and Joe
Biden's just along how many times has he
said something publicly and then they
come out and correct it exactly I mean
multiple times that's why that's why I
don't think a lot we've argued this
before people are like he's clearly not
making the call someone's doing it for
him and I'm like no no I think he is but
they're just shrugging and then doing
random things so when he goes out on TV
and says a thing
they have to come out and correct them
now think about what happens behind
closed doors he's telling them what to
do and then they're doing whatever they
want so I don't think they're going to
Biden and saying Biden you're going to
tell people to do this and he goes okay
I think they go in and Biden goes all
right here's what we're going to do
we're going to do this that better than
they're like you got it and they walk
out and say what are you guys going to
do I'm gonna do something else yeah and
I think they do have to and they've been
trying to do this they're trying to
manage him better I mean do you remember
when he came out and said red line with
Taiwan China invades Taiwan we're
showing up and they're like oh hey uh
timeout here's actually what he meant
yeah or when he said they're going to
get mad at me if I read this or ask
questions so everyone's like who's they
yeah who's the president there's like
just like you said like it's all this is
all evidence just you know that that he
isn't the guy in charge thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time